[Música]
llegó el momento de actualizar la
información económica aquí en directo
América y saludo nuevamente en el
estudio Daniel hablando Hola Andrés Dani
vamos a empezar en Estados Unidos los ex
ejecutivos de los bancos colapsados en
Wall Street rindieron testimonio en el
senado estuvo muy interesante esta
sesión en la que los altos ejecutivos de
silicon
evitaron asumir su responsabilidad por
las fallas dramáticas de sus bancos y en
su lugar usaron su tiempo para culpar de
la situación a eventos que dijeron
estaban en gran medida fuera de control
pero sus argumentos resultaron difíciles
de creer para los legisladores a
continuación tenemos algunos apartes de
esta acalorada sesión
11 días antes de que su banco quebrara
vendió acciones por un valor de 3.6
millones de dólares sabía en ese momento
que el silicon estaba en problemas no
senador no lo estaba es un evento sin
precedentes la corrida bancaria más
rápida de la historia desde nuestro
punto de vista Esa fue la anomalía no
esto no fue sin prece dentes fue hasta
los huesos hasta la médula
estúpido pusiste todos tus huevos en una
misma canasta y a menos que vivieras en
la estación espacial internacional
podrías ver que las tasas de interés
estaban aumentando y no estabas cubierto
Andrés tampoco quedó duda alguna sobre
si van a devolver el dinero o no de las
altísimas compensaciones que estaban
recibiendo poco antes de la quiebra
está planeando devolver un solo centavo
de lo que costó la quiebra al fondo de
garantías senadora sé que habrá un
proceso de revisión de la compensación
tomaré eso como un no entonces planea
regresar cuanto nada Eso es todo
no planeo hacerlo
está bien Así es la cosa en este momento
la ley dice que personas como el señor
Becker y el señor shey pueden venir a
Washington cabildear por regulaciones
bancarias más débiles cargar sus bancos
con riesgo recibir decenas de millones
de dólares en bonos y opciones sobre
acciones y cuando los bancos exploten el
señor Becker y el señor se quedan con
todo el dinero
terminan siendo los usuarios los
usuarios bancarios los culpables los que
pagan Así es vamos a quedarnos ahí en
Estados Unidos el camino para resolver
el problema del techo de la deuda para
estar despejarse cómo es eso por lo
menos
cambio de discurso por parte de los
republicanos su líder Kevin mccarthy
reconoció que no era imposible llegar a
un acuerdo antes de que se acabe esta
semana aunque las posiciones Todavía
están muy lejos al menos de dos semanas
de que el país entre eventualmente en un
incumplimiento de pagos yobaiden viaja a
Japón este fin de semana pero canceló el
resto de viajes para concentrarse en
este tema
Dani y Qué tan grave es la deuda de
Estados Unidos es bastante grave porque
la gran mayoría de ingresos que tiene un
país son los impuestos y lo ideal sería
que esos ingresos alcanzaran para cubrir
todos los gastos pero esto no es así en
Estados Unidos por lo menos desde el
2001 cuando fue la última vez que tuvo
superávit desde entonces se viene
acumulando déficits que se han dado por
recortes de impuestos por guerras por la
gran recesión después otro recorte de
impuestos y al final su peor momento
llega con la pandemia cuando puso
cientos de miles de millones de dólares
en los bolsillos de los ciudadanos y
generó un amplio déficit y vamos a dejar
Estados Unidos para irnos hasta el
Salvador allí ensayan con bancos
comunitarios Para apoyar a mujeres con
escasos recursos bueno con estas tasas
de interés tan altas se podría hacer una
buena idea a miles de mujeres en ese
país es centroamericano les es casi
imposible conseguir un crédito en el
sistema bancario porque no tienen un
trabajo que les brinde las prestaciones
de ley establecidas por eso surgió una
iniciativa de bancos comunitarios en el
municipio de a 47 kilómetros de la
capital San Salvador con el que cientos
de mujeres han logrado emprender algún
tipo de negocio allí logran por ejemplo
tasas de interés del 10% anual con
pequeños montos de préstamos que van
entre 50 y 500 dólares y que son
financiados con un comité de ahorro
entre ellas mismas también apoyados por
organizaciones no gubernamentales sin
duda una mujer campesina que no tiene
esas condiciones laborales le van a
hacer un préstamo un crédito en un banco
ellas hablan de la economía bueno Y
nosotras no somos obreras verdad porque
no no trabajan en una fábrica no son
empleadas públicas no son este bueno son
mujeres de las comunidades rurales son
campesinas pero quieren tener economía
quieren saber Cómo administrar
económicamente un recurso que tengan a
la en sus manos verdad sin duda una
buena iniciativa Daniela y usted nos
prometió cifra del día Cuál es la cifras
son los 175 millones de dólares esta fue
la cifra que llevó a la famosa tienda
neoyorquina Century 21 a la quiebra
durante la pandemia en 2020 pues hoy
reabren estas icónicas tiendas en ese
momento sus proveedores de seguros se
negaron a pagar esa cantidad de deudada
en pólizas para proteger a la empresa de
las pérdidas que sufrió por la crisis
pero ya está de vuelta y la cifra
podrían ser las enormes filas las miles
de personas que están aglutinadas en las
tiendas de centurington igual hay
quienes dicen que es el secreto mejor
guardado de Nueva York yo puedo
confirmarlo es muy buena pueden
confirmarlo Daniel Muchas gracias por la
información económica y nos vemos mañana
entonces con una nueva jornada aquí
estaré mañana